[Music]
is that that guy Robert again listen
concession stand girl
why don't you give me your number
wait you never said where he goes to
school I think he just works
[Music]
oysters come on
he has cats his eyes are nice they
crinkle yeah because he's old
I think I really like him as promised
I'm not saying I will have sex with him
I think he was like
he was like
listen to me call it a night hey do we
want to do this
this is the worst life decision I've
ever made
I had a good time tonight
didn't you
so what was his go-to move the reverse
squatting cowgirl where's cats at least
cute
I never saw them oh
why lie about having cats
because like in cats makes a guy seem
non-threatening harmless
he's hiding something
[Music]
I need to keep someone away from me you
scared me people choose to be scared
can't say I'm surprised to find lovely
ladies like yourselves in here looking
for protection Kelvin you need to shut
that down right now
what is the matter with you you
manipulated me
so he called you
if you want to get along with a man
cannot be alone your whole entire life
make peace
well little
discomfort
one of us has to die
thank you
[Music]